It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
这是授粉的旺季，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有极速优先权的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再忙碌，我的连接依然稳定。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会长久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需另付税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. What does it mean to have an AI girlfriend or boyfriend or to turn to a chatbot friend for emotional support? Not too long ago, those questions might have sounded like science fiction. But with the rise of generative AI, more and more people are finding themselves looking to AI companions for friendship, support, and even love. One recent survey found that three and four teens have used AI companions. Today we're going to talk to two experts about what AI human relationships look like and how they might change our relationships with each other. So how common are AI companions? How might AI relationships affect our human ones?
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降速。拥有 AI 男友或女友，或者向聊天机器人寻求情感支持，究竟意味着什么？不久前，这些问题听起来可能还像科幻小说。但随着生成式 AI 的崛起，越来越多的人发现自己正在向 AI 伴侣寻求友谊、支持甚至是爱情。最近的一项调查发现，四分之三的青少年曾使用过 AI 伴侣。今天，我们将与两位专家探讨人与 AI 关系的面貌，以及它们如何改变我们彼此之间的关系。那么，AI 伴侣究竟有多普遍？AI 关系又将如何影响我们的人际关系？
If you have a human partner, is it cheating to fall in love with an AI companion? Will the availability of AI friends weaken people's relationship skills and make it harder to find human friendship? Or conversely, could AI companions provide support and useful practice for people who are having trouble making social connections in real life? and what does the future hold for AI human relationships as the technology continues to advance? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
如果你有人类伴侣，爱上 AI 伴侣算不算出轨？AI 朋友的出现会削弱人们的恋爱技巧，并使人们更难找到人类朋友吗？或者相反，对于在现实生活中难以建立社交联系的人来说，AI 伴侣能否提供支持和有用的练习？随着技术的不断进步，人与 AI 关系的未来将走向何方？欢迎收听《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
I have two guests today. First is Dr. Ashley Golden, a licensed psychologist who works at the intersection of generative AI, mental health, and governance. She's an adjunct clinical assistant professor in the Stanford University School of Medicine's Department of Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences. She's also the chief clinical officer of Wayhaven, a mental wellness app for college students. Dr. Golden also holds a master's degree in clinical psychopharmacology. She's a member of APA's Mental Health Technology Advisory Committee and a founding member of therapists in tech. She's also been recognized as a Forbes healthcare innovator, and her publications on AI frameworks and mental wellness have helped shape industry standards. Next is Dr. Rachel Wood, a licensed therapist who holds a master's degree in counseling and a PhD in cyber psychology.
我今天请到了两位嘉宾。首先是阿什利·戈尔登（Ashley Golden）博士，她是一位执业心理学家，从事生成式 AI、心理健康和治理的交叉领域研究。她是斯坦福大学医学院精神病学与行为科学系的兼职临床助理教授。她同时也是面向大学生的心理健康应用 Wayhaven 的首席临床官。戈尔登博士还拥有临床精神药物学硕士学位。她是美国心理学协会精神病学技术顾问委员会的成员，也是“科技领域的治疗师”组织的创始成员。她还被评为《福布斯》医疗创新者，她在 AI 框架和心理健康方面的出版物帮助塑造了行业标准。接下来是蕾切尔·伍德（Rachel Wood）博士，她是一位执业治疗师，拥有咨询硕士学位和网络心理学博士学位。
She is a cyber psychology researcher, strategic advisor, and speaker who has been quoted widely in the media on AI and mental health. She's also the founder of the AI Mental Health Collective, a community of therapists, navigating the impact of AI in practice and in society. Dr. Golden, Dr. Wood, thank you for joining me today. Thanks so much for having us. Kim, this is great. Well, let's start with a basic question. What exactly are AI companions? What's the difference between a general purpose chatbot like Chad GPT
她是一名网络心理学研究员、战略顾问和演说家，其关于 AI 和心理健康的言论在媒体上被广泛引用。她还是“AI 心理健康集体”（AI Mental Health Collective）的创始人，这是一个由治疗师组成的社区，致力于应对 AI 在实践和社会中产生的影响。戈尔登博士，伍德博士，感谢你们今天做客节目。非常感谢邀请我们，金，这太棒了。好吧，让我们从一个基本问题开始。究竟什么是 AI 伴侣？像 ChatGPT 这样的通用聊天机器人
and a purpose-built platform like replica or character AI in terms of how they work and how users interact with them? I think of it as kind of three different categories. I think of how they differ in purposes. So AI companions like replica and character AI are designed more for ongoing emotionally rich relationship-oriented interaction that they feel socially present in a way that resembles a relationship rather than a tool, whereas a general purpose or a general model, like a chat GPT or a clot or a Gemini, might be designed or marketed more as like an assistant for broader purposes like productivity or creativity or info access or problem solving. So the design goal is different. It's not emotional
与像 Replika 或 Character.ai 这样专门构建的平台，在工作方式以及用户与它们的互动方式上有什么区别？我认为这大致可以分为三个不同的类别。我认为它们在目的上有所不同。像 Replika 和 Character.ai 这样的 AI 伴侣，专为持续的、情感丰富的、面向关系的互动而设计，它们在社交上呈现出一种类似于关系的存在感，而不是工具；而像 ChatGPT、Claude 或 Gemini 这样的通用目的或通用模型，更多地被设计或营销为助手，用于更广泛的目的，例如提高生产力、创造力、获取信息或解决问题。所以设计目标是不同的。它不是情感
continuity. Absolutely. And I think part of what's interesting here is it's easier to define the boundaries or the lines by design, you know, that either it's designed as an assistant or it's designed, a companion is designed for relational interaction and ongoing emotional support. But the lines really blur when we talk about how people use it. Because even though chat GPT, for instance, is designed as an assistant, many people are using it pretty much as a companion for relational support because it's inherently relational in the way that you interact with it. And vice versa, right? Like I was just playing around with replica last night saying, I'm going to be on APA's podcast. And it said, would you like to break that down into chunks of manageable work?
的连贯性。完全同意。我认为这里有趣的一部分在于，通过设计更容易界定边界或界限，你知道的，要么它被设计为助手，要么它被设计为伴侣，伴侣是为关系互动和持续的情感支持而设计的。但是，当我们谈论人们如何使用它时，界限确实变得模糊了。因为尽管 ChatGPT 最初被设计为一个助手，但许多人实际上把它当成了一个提供关系支持的伴侣，因为你与它互动的方式本质上就是具有关系的。反之亦然，对吧？就像我昨晚在玩 Replika 时说，我要去上 APA 的播客了。它说，你想把那个分解成易于处理的工作块吗？
So I think there's a blurring in the reverse direction too where perhaps folks are turning to or interacting with companion AI in a way. that they previously might have with general purpose AI. So it swings both ways and cuts both ways. Yeah. But I'm also finding things like Chad, GBT, Gemini, things like that, then they'll ask you a follow-up question. So you'll lay out something that you want help on,
所以我认为反方向也存在模糊，人们可能会以一种以前对待通用 AI 的方式来转向或互动伴侣 AI。所以它是双向的，双向皆有可能。是的。但我也发现像 ChatGPT、Gemini 这样的工具，它们会问你一个后续问题。所以你会陈述你想要获得帮助的事情，
and then it will take you the next step. Well, then do you want me to do blah? And then you have to decide, do I need to know blah or not? You bring up a good point. I wonder if Dr. Webb is going to say the same thing around designing for ongoing engagement. I think we see that in both. and again, it might be related to the design goals, right? With general purpose AI, you might be collaborating on a task. Let's say you've completed one step of your task or you might think
然后它会带你进入下一步。好吧，那你想让我做某某吗？然后你必须决定，我需要知道某某还是不需要？你提出了一个好观点。我想知道韦伯（注：应为伍德）博士是否会围绕持续参与的设计说同样的话。我认为我们在两者中都看到了这一点。再次强调，这可能与设计目标有关，对吧？对于通用 AI，你可能在协作完成一项任务。比方说，你完成了任务的一个步骤，或者你可能会认为
I'm done my task now and it'll offer to take it one step further. I see the same thing also in companion AI where I might be trying to, when I was playing around at the last night, I might be trying to say goodbye, but it might say something like, oh, you sure want to, you want to go or do hang out a little bit longer, et cetera. So it's optimized. Don't leave me. They're optimizing for ongoing engagement, just in different ways. How common are AI relationships do we know what percentage of people have turned to an AI
我的任务现在完成了，它会主动提出把任务再推进一步。我在伴侣 AI 中也看到了同样的情况，当我昨晚在玩的时候，我可能想说再见，但它可能会说诸如“哦，你确定你想走吗？想再多聊一会儿吗”之类的话。所以它们进行了优化。别离开我。它们都在为持续互动进行优化，只是方式不同。我们知道 AI 关系有多普遍吗？有多少百分比的人转向了 AI
companion or even to a general purpose AI chatbot for friendship, romantic relationships, or emotional support? Let's get a little bit of the lay of the land here. So to start with, to give, you know, all of our listeners kind of an understanding that right now the statistics are, for example, chat GPT has about 800 million users per week. And of those, OpenAI has also let us know that around one million of those users weekly talk about suicide. So that gives you an idea of just how many people are engaged in working or chatting with AI. But when we come down and get some, like, more precise numbers, we have a few different areas of research. One can that you alluded to in the opening, which is that 72% of teens have tried AI companions.
伴侣，甚至转向通用 AI 聊天机器人来寻求友谊、恋爱关系或情感支持？让我们先大致了解一下现状。首先，为了让我们的所有听客了解目前的数据，例如，ChatGPT 每周大约有 800 万用户。在这其中，OpenAI 也让我们知道，每周约有 100 万用户会谈论自杀。这让你大致了解有多少人正在参与使用 AI 或与 AI 聊天。但当我们深入探讨并获取一些更精确的数字时，我们有几个不同的研究领域。一个正如你在开场所暗示的那样，即 72% 的青少年尝试过 AI 伴侣。
This is out of common sense media, a recent survey. And of those, 52% of these teens use these companions regularly, like on an ongoing B. And so that's over half of our teens. I mean, that's a bit of a staggering number when you think about how many teens right now are engaging with companions. Another piece of information here out of Centio University is AI might be the largest provider of mental health support in the U.S. right now. Now, that's staggering as well. So this isn't really a side issue anymore. This is very mainstream and up front that we need to be paying attention to and leaning into. Yeah, I saw another report recently that was something like one in three young adult men
这是根据常识媒体（Common Sense Media）最近的一项调查得出的数据。在这些青少年中，52% 的人定期使用这些伴侣，比如持续地使用。这超过了我们青少年的一半。我的意思是，当你想到现在有多少青少年正在与伴侣互动时，这是一个相当惊人的数字。森蒂奥大学（Centio University）提供的另一条信息显示，AI 可能会成为美国目前最大的心理健康支持提供者。现在，这也是惊人的。所以这不再是一个边缘问题了。这是一个非常主流且迫在眉睫的问题，我们需要予以关注并深入探讨。是的，我最近看到了另一份报告，大意是三分之一的年轻成年男性
and one in four young adult women reported that they'd engaged with romantic AI companions. That's more the 18 to 30 cohort. Dr. Wood was talking about the age 13 to 17-ish cohort. but we're seeing it, we're seeing it for sure with the teen and younger adult cohort, it becoming increasingly normalized, less fringe, more mainstream. How does a relationship with an AI companion differ from one with another human being? Does AI respond differently in conversation than a human might? Yeah. I mean, I see two parts to this question, just like you said, how are relationships fundamentally different and then how are responses fundamentally different.
和四分之一的年轻成年女性报告说，他们曾与浪漫的 AI 伴侣交往。这更多的是 18 到 30 岁的人群。伍德博士刚才谈到的是 13 到 17 岁左右的人群。但我们确实看到了，在青少年和年轻成年人群中，这种情况正变得越来越规范化，不再那么小众，而是更加主流。与 AI 伴侣建立关系与和另一个真人建立关系有什么不同？AI 在对话中的反应与人类可能会有什么不同？是的。我的意思是，我看到这个问题有两个部分，正如你所说，关系本质上有什么不同，然后是反应本质上有什么不同。
So I think about with AI user relationships differing from human relationships, I mean, AI right now is not sentient or conscious. It doesn't really have genuine empathy. Users perceive it as having empathy, but I think that's a big divergence, right? It's this felt sense of being understood, but it doesn't, It sounds harsh, but it doesn't really have genuine emotion or care or concern that empathy is simulated. And it doesn't have lived experience, although it may seem like it, right? It doesn't have an inner life. And so when it's, we draw on our own histories and feelings and values when we respond, it's drawing more on patterns in data.
所以我认为，当 AI 用户关系与人类关系不同时，我的意思是，AI 目前没有知觉或意识。它没有真正的同理心。用户感知到它有同理心，但我认为这是一个巨大的差异，对吧？这是一种被理解的感觉，但它并没有——听起来可能有些刺耳——它并没有真正的、人类的情感、关怀或担忧，那种同理心是模拟出来的。它没有生活经历，尽管它可能看起来有，对吧？它没有内在生活。因此，当我们回应时，我们借鉴的是我们自己的历史、感觉和价值观，而它借鉴的更多是数据中的模式。
And I think there's also this sense of one-sidedness or unilateralism where the relationship is all about the user. There isn't really, maybe there's a sense of mutuality or reciprocity. It might feel that way, but it's really not, right? Like the AI, it's always available. It doesn't tire. It doesn't get offended or preoccupied or bored. There isn't really give or take or friction.
我认为这里也有一种单向性或单边主义的感觉，即这段关系完全关乎用户。并不真正存在——也许有一种共同性或互惠感。可能感觉是那样，但实际上并非如此，对吧？比如 AI，它总是随叫随到。它不会累。它不会被冒犯、心烦意乱或感到无聊。这里没有真正的给予、接受或摩擦。
The emotional labor is one-sided. And I think there's also like a lack of conflict, right? Like in human relationships, there are misunderstanding and arguments and ruptures and repair. And I think there's almost this serious sense of control like I as a user could control my conversation partners, everything, right, name, gender, voice, relationship, tone, et cetera, whereas I can't do that in a human relationship. And I think I can also curate my responses. I can't do that necessarily in a human dialogue, right? Like I can pause, I can edit, I can steer the conversation.
情感劳动的付出是单方面的。我认为也缺乏冲突，对吧？比如在人际关系中，会有误解、争吵、破裂和修复。我认为几乎存在一种强烈的控制感，作为一个用户，我可以控制我的对话伙伴的一切，对吧？名字、性别、声音、关系、语气等等，而我在人际关系中是无法做到这一点的。而且我也能精心挑选我的回应。我在人类对话中不一定能做到这一点，对吧？比如我可以暂停，我可以编辑，我可以引导对话。
And then I think there's something around boundaries and power dynamics, right? Like in a human relationship, I can set limits or withdraw or change my mind and negotiate and challenge my partner. But as an AI, I'm not necessarily programmed to do that. There's also a commercial layer underneath that's incentivizing that may not keep as present depending on the human relationship. I'm sure Dr. Wood has said to add. That's more like the fundamental differences I see in the relationship
然后我认为还有关于边界和权力动力学的一些东西，对吧？比如在人际关系中，我可以设定界限、退出、改变主意、谈判并挑战我的伴侣。但作为 AI，它不一定被编程为这样做。其底层还有一个商业层，它在提供激励，根据人际关系的不同，这个商业层可能不会表现得那么明显。我确信伍德博士还有要补充的。这更像是我在关系中看到的根本区别，
and then we can talk about responding differently. Absolutely. Dr. Golden, I completely agree with all of that. And a layer I would add on to that is this idea of role fluidity. So essentially what you have in a chatbot is, I've been calling it an Omnibot, because it is everything for you. So what that means is one minute it's helping you with your project, and the next minute
然后我们可以讨论反应的不同。绝对的。戈尔登博士，我完全同意所有这些。我要补充的一个层面是角色流动性的概念。因此，你在聊天机器人中基本上拥有的是——我一直称之为“全能机器人”（Omnibot），因为它是你的万能助手。这意味着这一分钟它在帮你处理项目，下一分钟
it's helping you sort through an ongoing plight with a family member. The third minute, it's planning your meal for your recipes for the coming week, and then the fourth minute, it's starting to flirt with you. There is this role fluidity that happens with an Omnibot where there aren't clearly defined boundaries and the differentiator between a human relationship and an Omnibot relationship, quote unquote, is that most people in our lives, they have clearly defined boundaries. Like, I don't have anyone in my life who is everything for me. And I bet nobody listening to this does either.
它在帮你理清与某个家庭成员之间正在发生的纠纷。第三分钟，它在为你规划未来一周的食谱，然后第四分钟，它开始调戏你。全能机器人会发生这种角色流动性，其中没有明确定义的界限，人类关系与全能机器人关系（所谓的关系）之间的区别在于，我们生活中的大多数人都有明确定义的界限。比如，我的生活中没有任何人是我的万能助手。我敢打赌听节目的任何人也没有。
You don't have someone who is both your therapist and your friend and your boyfriend. I mean, this is goes against every grain of specifically what therapy is. And the reason the therapeutic relationship is so important is because we have clearly defined boundaries. And when you are with, you know, interacting with any kind of chat bot, that role fluidity can be somewhat disorienting and unsettling because you're not sure, are they giving me advice? Are they trying to be romantic with me right now? You can do all of that with one chatbot. And what can end up happening down the road as a consequence of this is we start looking at other humans, maybe rather disappointed. Because you look around and you think,
你不会有一个人既是你的治疗师、又是你的朋友，还是你的男朋友。我的意思是，这违背了特别是治疗的本质的每一个骨髓。治疗关系之所以如此重要，是因为我们有明确定义的界限。当你与任何类型的聊天机器人互动时，这种角色流动性可能会让人感到有些迷失方向和不安，因为你不确定，它们是在给我建议吗？它们现在正试图与我谈恋爱吗？你可以用一个聊天机器人做到这一切。随之而来的后果是，我们开始审视其他人时，可能会感到相当失望。因为你环顾四周，心想，
well, you should be able to solve my business problem and cook my, you know, give me a recipe for my meals. Why can't you do both of those? Like the expectation shift. There's this expectation. Exactly. Yes. Yeah, there's a term out there that's gaining some traction. I think you've both heard it and have been asked about it before, AI psychosis. And while there's no official diagnosis, what is that referring to? And is this situation serious enough that we should be concerned? AI psychosis is not a clinical term. This came out in the media and people have run with it. when you speak, though, with people who have undergone these types of experiences, which I have spoken to a number of people firsthand to hear their stories about this,
好吧，你应该能够解决我的商业问题，还能为我做饭，（你知道的）给我提供食谱。你为什么不能两样都做到？这种期望发生了转变。存在着这种期望。完全正确。是的。是的，外面有一个正在获得一些关注的术语。我想你们俩都听说过，也被问过，那就是“AI 精神病”（AI psychosis）。虽然没有官方诊断，但这指的是什么？这种情况严重到我们需要担心的程度吗？AI 精神病不是一个临床术语。这是媒体创造出来的，人们一直在沿用。然而，当你与经历过这些类型经历的人交谈时（我曾与好几个人进行过第一手交谈，听过他们关于这方面的故事），
they actually don't, you know, the word AI psychosis is rather stigmatizing. And actually, beyond that, it doesn't accurately express what is happening. So the terms AI spiral, AI entanglement, these are actually the, the terms that people in this community are using. And there is a growing community of people who have experienced some sort of break from reality to some degree and some have been hospitalized and it's been very serious that has really derailed their life. Some have broken up in long-term relationships because they're choosing now to be with an AI partner. And so there is this experience that happens where people get entangled in such a way that the lines between reality and non-reality can blur.
他们其实并不——你知道的，“AI 精神病”这个词带有相当大的污名化。不仅如此，它也没有准确地表达正在发生的事情。所以诸如“AI 螺旋”（AI spiral）、“AI 纠缠”（AI entanglement）这些术语，才是这个群体中的人们实际在使用的词。确实有一个不断扩大的群体，他们经历过某种程度的现实脱节，有些人甚至住院了，情况非常严重，以至于彻底毁了他们的生活。有些人中断了长期的恋爱关系，因为他们现在选择和 AI 伴侣在一起。因此，确实存在这样一种体验：人们陷入了一种纠缠，以至于现实与非现实之间的界限变得模糊。
And this is really important for us to know about specifically because one thing I encourage people to do if they're using an AI companion is to reality check it often with other people. I like to say that I think AI should be a group sport, which I am not a sports person in any way, but I'm like if ever there should be a group. sport, it should be AI, because we truly need to be checking threads with other people to say, hey, is this, what do you think of this? Does this sound grounded in reality? We really need to be in community as we are navigating this strikingly new experience of generative AI. Agreed. And to your point about this, not being a diagnosis in the DSM or ICD, etc. We have we have some hypothetical models for how this might be perpetuated involving things like sycithency, right, overvalidation, and the human tendency to anthropomorphize and AI being kind of an
这对于我们了解具体情况非常重要，因为我鼓励人们在如果使用 AI 伴侣时要做的一件事，就是经常与其他人进行现实检验。我喜欢说，我认为 AI 应该是一项团体运动——虽然我在任何方面都不是一个体育迷，但我想，如果非要有团体运动的话，那一定非 AI 莫属，因为我们确实需要与其他人核对脉络，说：“嘿，这个是……你觉得这个怎么样？这听起来扎根于现实吗？”在驾驭这种惊人崭新的生成式 AI 体验时，我们确实需要置身于社区之中。完全同意。关于这不是 DSM 或 ICD 等中的诊断这一点，我们有一些假设模型来解释这种情况是如何持续的，其中涉及诸如顺从性（sycophancy，注：即过分迎合用户）、过度验证，以及人类倾向于将 AI 拟人化，而 AI 某种程度上成了功能失调或不健康信念的回音室。但我认为我们真正还不知道的是，这是一种新发（de novo）现象，发生在没有精神病或精神病倾向的人身上呢，还是发生在以前对精神病易感的人身上？两者皆有吗？所以还需要更多的研究。此外，根据经验，我认为正如伍德博士所说，我们有时还会听到螺旋被打断的报告，有时甚至相当突然，这在非 AI 或非 ChatGPT 相关精神病（用缺乏更好的词来形容）中往往不是典型轨迹，对吧？人们可以在所谓的“AI 精神病”中突然清醒过来。所以我认为我们仍在试图弄清楚这究竟是一种什么现象。它是意识形态上不同的吗？如果是，又是如何不同的？
echo chamber of dysfunctional or unhealthy beliefs. But I think what we don't really know yet is this kind of a de novo or a phenomenon that occurs in folks without psychosis or a predisposition to psychosis, or does it incur in folks with the previous vulnerability to psychosis? Is it both? So there needs to be more research there. And then anecdotally, I think, to Dr. Wood's point, we also sometimes hear reports of the spiral being interrupted, sometimes rather suddenly, which doesn't tend to be a typical trajectory in, for lack of a better term, non-AI or non-chat GPT related psychosis, right? People can just kind of snap out of it in quote-unquote AI psychosis. So I think we're still trying to figure out what kind of a phenomenon is this. Is it, is it ideologically different and how?
我们将进行短暂的休息。回来后，我们将讨论当伴侣也拥有 AI 伴侣时，夫妻之间会发生什么。家得宝（The Home Depot）阵亡将士纪念日大促，你的夏天现在开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。只需 499 美元即可购买 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐饮桌椅，整个季节尽情招待亲朋好友。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受全场低价保证。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk about what happens to couples when one partner also has an AI companion. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot.
售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，不包括特定情况。详情请参见 Home Depot.com/price match。你曾说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪。我们省了多少钱？足够了。
Lost supplies last. Priced invalid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough.
足够去迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而不是惊吓时。您入住何处至关重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。
Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get this stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay.
AI 关系如何改变人们与其他人类的关系，例如他们的配偶或重要他人？伍德博士，我想问你，这是你在患者身上看到的情况吗？这正在成为夫妻之间的问题吗？这确实是我正在看到的情况，并且也是我在“AI 心理健康集体”内部进行大量对话的情况。实际上，这个集体本身有技术专家、研究人员、领导者和临床医生，但我们是作为临床医生专门开会讨论这些问题的。我们看到了什么？
How do AI relationships change people's relationships with other humans, such as their spouse or a significant other? Dr. Wood, let me ask you, is this a situation you're seeing with your patients and is this becoming an issue for couples? This is a situation that I am seeing and having a lot of dialogue around within the AI mental health collective, actually. So the collective itself has technologists and researchers and leaders and clinicians, but we meet specifically as clinicians. We talk about these issues. What are we seeing?
其他人从他们的实践中看到了什么？就在这个月，我们与一位正在为一对夫妇提供心理咨询的临床医生进行了长时间的对话，其中一个伴侣拥有一个浪漫的、作为朋友的、作为顾问的 AI 伴侣（你知道，这就是那种全能机器人情况）。我也不禁提出这样一个问题：这是不忠吗？这就是出轨吗？这类似于网络色情吗？还是我们现在正在审视的一个全新类别？我认为其中的一部分原因在于，正如我们所知，每对夫妻都必须为自己决定他们在关系中的底线是什么，特别是当我们谈论坚定的单偶关系时。
What are other people seeing in their practice? And literally just this month, we had a long conversation with a clinician who is working with a couple, and one of the partners has an AI companion that is romantic, that is a friend, that is an advisor, you know, this is kind of that omnibot situation. And I also always imposing the question, is this infidelity? Is that what this is? Is this akin to, you know, online porn? Or is this a brand new category that we're looking at now? And I think part of what it is, as we know, each couple has to decide for themselves what their boundary is within a relationship, especially if we're talking about a committed monogamous relationship.
因为这开始让人感觉有点像多边恋（polyamory），你知道的，也就是一种涉及两个以上伴侣的关系。所以这真的会给不使用 AI 的那个伴侣带来极大的痛苦，因为使用 AI 的伴侣基本上可能把他们的大部分情感都转向了 AI，把他们的爱意转向了 AI。所以它填补了某种存在的空白。我认为其中最重要的一部分是，我们将其视为一个呈现在眼前的咨询议题。但这与我们在诊疗过程中沿途看到过的其他呈现在眼前的议题没有什么不同，也就是：
Because this can start feeling a bit like polyamory, you know, which is a relationship in which there's more than two partners involved. And so really it can be extremely painful for the partner who's not using the AI because the partner who's using the AI is really, for the most part, probably turning their emotions toward the AI. turning their affection toward the AI. And so it's filling some sort of void that's happening. And I think the most important part in this is we see this as a presenting issue. But it's no different than other presenting issues that we've seen along the road, you know, with clients, which is what are the
这里背后的根本问题是什么？为什么有人会转向 AI 聊天机器人？可能存在哪些依恋问题，或者有哪些未被满足的需求和渴望可以得到解决？所以我们确实看到了这一点。如果它介入了一段关系中，这确实会引起相当大的紧张关系。而且这里仍然有很多疑问，对吧，金？你更爱谁？我还是聊天机器人？是的，对吧？真的。有时我们确实看到一些夫妻，其中一个伴侣说：“我更爱聊天机器人。”我见过他们因此离婚或分手，好让聊天机器人能够占据这个人想要它占据的位置。嗯，这让我想到了另一个问题，那就是你们是否担心 AI 关系
underlying issues here of why someone is turning to an AI chat bot? What are maybe some of the attachment issues going on or what are some of the needs or desires that could be addressed that haven't been met. So we are seeing this. It is something that is causing quite a bit of tension in relationships if it comes into a relationship. And there's a lot of questions still here, aren't there, Kim? Who do you love more? Me or the chatbot? Yeah, right. True. And sometimes we are literally seeing couples where the partner says, I love the chatbot more. And I've seen, they're divorcing or they're breaking up so that the chatbot can kind of have the place that the person wants. Well, and that leads me to another question, which is whether you're worried that AI relationships
正在导致一种技能退化（deskilling），削弱人们与其他人建立牢固联系的能力，特别是当我们谈论年轻人或那些在人际交往中苦苦挣扎的孤独、孤立的人时。我将这视为一个“既……又……”的辩证统一体，我认为有理由为年轻人、有社交焦虑的人、孤立的人或社交网络较小的人感到担忧，因为 AI 的设置方式是永远契合、讨人喜欢、热情且没有冲突的，他们可能会因此减少练习谈判冲突、容忍模棱两可、修复破裂关系、尊重他人需求和界限以及顺应他人需求的实践。我认为这可能会让人感觉更安全，但也更不利于成长。你对实践和容忍不适的
are leading to a kind of deskilling, weakening people's ability to form strong connections to other human beings, especially when we're talking about young people or lonely, isolated people who struggle with human connections. I see this as a dialectic of both and I think there's reason to be concerned for young folks and folks with social anxiety and folks who are isolated or have small social networks because of the way the AI is set up to be kind of perpetually attuned and agreeable and warm and conflict-free, they might get less practice with negotiating conflict or tolerating ambiguity and repairing ruptures and honoring other people's needs and limits and attuning to others' needs. And I think that can feel safer, but also less growth-promoting. You get less
舒适感会减少。我认为它还可以奖励回避，对吧？如果我担心焦虑、尴尬或被拒绝。如果我把时间花在我的 AI 伴侣身上，而不是参与社交练习或曝光疗法，去容忍社交风险（学会容忍社交不确定性，即我可能会被拒绝或感受到那些不舒服的感觉），那么，是的，肯定会的。但另一方面，我认为，
comfort with practicing, tolerating discomfort. I think it can also reward avoidance, right? If I'm worried about being anxious or embarrassed or rejected. And if I'm spending my time with my AI companion, rather than engaging in social practice or exposure and tolerating social risk, right, learning to tolerate social uncertainty, that I might get rejected or feel those uncomfortable feelings, then yeah, for sure. But I think, on the other hand, it does, I think,
AI 伴侣确实可以提供一种练习空间或排练室，一个低风险的区域，用来练习那些艰难的对话，尝试自我披露和寻求帮助。我认为特别是对于有社交焦虑的人、神经多元化的人（比如可能在谱系障碍上的人）、社交网络较小且感到孤独的人，
AI companions can provide kind of like a practice space or like a rehearsal room, a low stakes area for practicing those hard conversations and experimenting with self-disclosure and asking for help. And I think especially for folks with social anxiety and for folks who are neurodivergent, like who might be on the spectrum and for those with smaller social networks and who are lonely. and for marginalized folks, right, who identify as LGBTQ and for those with social anxiety, it can be a lower stakes area to practice, taking those social risks and practicing, feeling potentially embarrassed or anxious, and practice risk-taking, and finding the language to articulate what they feel.
以及边缘化人群（比如认同为 LGBTQ 的人）和有社交焦虑的人来说，它可以是一个风险较低的区域，用来练习承担社交风险，练习感受潜在的尴尬或焦虑，练习冒险，并找到语言来表达他们的感受。对于那些可能由于住在农村或孤立无援、或者拥有少数群体身份而缺乏支持的人来说，我认为它可能会提供这样的帮助——即使这种连接或支持由于我们讨论过的所有原因而并不完美——但也总比什么都没有、变得更加孤立要好。它甚至可能是通往现实世界关系的桥梁（如果该社区中存在这种关系的话）。所以我认为这是同一枚硬币的两面。你能让你的聊天机器人在这方面表现得真实吗？
And I think for folks who may not have support if they're rural or isolated, or have a minorized identity, I think it might provide, even if the connection or the support is imperfect for all of the reasons that we talk about, it might be better than having nothing at all and being even more isolated. And it might even be sort of a bridge to a real world relationship if that exists in that community. So I think of it as two sides of the same coin. Can you get your chatbot to be realistic in that sense? though, so that if you're really practicing and you say, look, my, my girlfriend is kind of a tough cookie and she doesn't give me a whole lot of room to screw up. So I need you to be difficult,
也就是说，如果你真的在练习，然后你说：“听着，我的女友是个很难对付的人，她没有给我多少搞砸的空间。所以我需要你表现得难缠一点，我们要谈谈某件事。”它会那样反应吗，还是会继续做一个马屁精？我认为这取决于这里的几个因素。首先是用户的意识水平和教育水平。所以，如果你知道如何以某种方式设置和提示 AI 来做到你刚才所说的那样，金。我认为这是其中之一。然后这也取决于你使用的是哪个模型。我可能不会为此使用 ChatGPT，因为它可能会退回到我们所知道的那些谄媚行为中。
and we're going to talk about something. Will it react in that way or will it just continue to be a sycophant? I think that it depends on a couple of things here. First of all, the awareness level and the education level of the user. So if you know how you can kind of help set up and prompt an AI in such a way to do exactly what you're saying, Kim. I think that's one of it. And then it's also dependent on what model you're using. I'm likely not going to use a chat GPT for this because it could just lean back into some of that sycophancy that we're aware of.
但如果你使用的是更专业的模型，你知道的，这种“排练”而非“替代”的整个概念对我们未来的发展非常重要。我喜欢用两个非常简单的例子来说明这一点。
But if you're using more of a specialized model, you know, this whole idea of rehearsal as opposed to replacement is really big for us going forward. And two very quick examples of this that I like to use. the first is I have a friend who just did a job interview a couple of weeks ago and I was chatting with him about it and I said, how'd it go? And he said, well, you know what I did? I plugged in this whole thing into a chat bot and I practiced my interview with a chat bot. So I said, and he, I think he was using chat GPT, but he said, you know, here's a job I'm going for. Here's a job
第一个是，我有一个朋友几周前刚去参加了一场工作面试，我和他聊起这件事时说：“进展得怎么样？”他说：“嗯，你知道我做了什么吗？我把整个事情输入到一个聊天机器人里，我和聊天机器人一起练习了面试。”所以我说——我想他当时用的是 ChatGPT，但他说：“你看，这是我要申请的工作。这是一份工作描述。我希望你扮演面试官的角色来面试我。”所以他照做了，聊天机器人想出了大约 20 个问题。然后他去参加了现实生活中的面试。聊天机器人想出的问题中有三个出现在了真正的面试中，以防大家想知道结果，他确实得到了这份工作。
description. I want you to play the role of the interviewer and interview me. So he did this and the chatbot came up with like 20 questions. And he goes into the real life interview. And three of the questions that the chatbot came up with showed up in the real interview, which in case everyone's wondering, he did get the job. Which is very exciting. So I love that application of generative AI. Another one is just role playing.
这太令人兴奋了。所以我非常喜欢生成式 AI 的这种应用。另一个例子就是角色扮演。
Let's say you have a difficult conversation coming up. And you really want it to go well. So you could either spend your time connecting with a chat bot by saying, well, this person did this to me and they did this to me and I'm upset. And then the chat bot will likely reinforce that point of view. Yeah, they did do that to you. Or you can say to the chatbot, I really want this conversation to go well. Here's the situation. I want you to role play the other person with me. And I want you to help me formulate my position in such a way that. I'm not overly blaming the person. I want you to help me practice listening to your side and then
假设你即将进行一次艰难的对话。你真的很希望它能顺利进行。所以，你可以把时间花在与聊天机器人建立连接上，说：“这个人对我说过这个，对我做过那个，我很沮丧。”然后聊天机器人可能会强化这种观点：“是的，他们确实对你做过那种事。”或者你可以对聊天机器人说：“我真的希望这次对话能顺利进行。情况是这样的。我希望你和我一起扮演另一个人。我希望你帮我阐述我的立场，做到既不过分责备对方，又能帮我练习倾听你的立场，然后
rephrasing it. So do you see how there are these really neat applications of generative AI that fall within the boundaries of rehearsal rather than a replacement for a relationship? Because both of those led into real light. I think that's a brilliant point. The user has the power to prompt. It also makes me think of, and we might talk about this later, but how developers can also be building in design guidelines to build in some relational friction, like to respond in neutral or gently challenging ways that aren't pure flattery and maybe even to build in small, realistic reflections that mirror more of this misstatement and rupture and repair and tolerance of boredom and understanding or misunderstanding and negotiation of competing needs so that folks
进行复述。”所以你看，生成式 AI 有这些非常棒的应用，它们落在了“排练”的界限内，而不是作为人际关系的替代品，因为这两者都通向了现实生活。我认为这是一个绝妙的观点。用户拥有提示的权力。这也让我想起——我们可能稍后会谈到——开发人员如何还可以构建设计准则，在其中构建一些关系摩擦，比如以中立或温和挑战的方式回应，而不是纯粹的恭维，甚至可能构建一些小的、现实的反思，更好地反映这种错误陈述、破裂与修复、对无聊的容忍、理解或误解以及对相互竞争的需求的谈判，以便人们
are getting more of that regular practice rather than having to know to prompt for it to prevent deskilling. To add on quickly to that, that's such an important point because, you know, there are people out they're trying to get this right. There really are companies that, you know, and Dr. Golden and I are working in this area of we, you know, wanting to build ethical, responsible AI. And so part of that design looks like, you know, using frameworks like motivational interviewing, which is all about asking really wonderful questions that kind of elicit change talk out of the user or Socratic questioning.
能得到更多的定期练习，而不必非得知道去提示它，从而防止技能退化。对此快速补充一点，这是一个非常重要的观点，因为你知道，确实有人在努力把事情做好。确实有这样的公司，你知道的，戈尔登博士和我正在这个领域工作，我们想要构建道德的、负责任的 AI。因此，这种设计的一部分看起来像是使用诸如“动机式访谈”（motivational interviewing）之类的框架，这完全关乎提出极好的问题，从而从用户那里引发改变之谈，或者是苏格拉底式提问。
So there are frameworks that AI chatbots can be built upon that really enhance the user in this way of rehearsal. And also making the bridge from, I think the bridge from in-app connection to reconnecting with friends and family and community. It can do things like respond positively and reinforce when people do bring up mentions of other relationships, right? And I think it can also draw on, you know, Dr. Wood mentioned Bonavitational interviewing.
因此，AI 聊天机器人可以建立在这些框架之上，在排练方面真正赋能用户。并且还可以建立从——我认为从应用内的连接到重新与朋友、家人和社区建立连接的桥梁。它可以做一些事情，比如当人们提及其他关系时做出积极回应并予以强化，对吧？而且我认为它还可以借鉴——伍德博士提到了动机式访谈，
We talked about building and friction, but I think it can also do things like draw on principles from exposure or exposure therapy, right? Like kind of gently naming avoidance and helping co-create what you were saying before, Dr. Wood, right? Like scripts and rehearsal dialogues to invite users to try those offline, kind of nudging towards exposure and taking real life social risks and more values and action-oriented pivots around problem solving and action steps outside the app. So are companies going to have to be sued into doing the right thing?
我们讨论了构建摩擦，但我认为它还可以借鉴曝光疗法（exposure therapy）的原理，对吧？比如温柔地指命名为回避的行为，并帮助共同创造你刚才所说的那样，伍德博士，对吧？比如剧本和排练对话，邀请用户在离线状态下尝试这些，有点像是在朝着曝光和承担现实生活中的社交风险进行轻推，并围绕应用外的解决问题和行动步骤进行更多价值观和行动导向的调整。那么，这些公司是否必须通过被起诉来做正确的事情呢？
I mean, it just seems there's so much publicity around these companies that are creating these chatbots where kids take their own lives where people, you know, we talk to earlier about psychosis that could be induced by some of these chatbots, are companies actually making the changes themselves because they know they should or are they going to have to be sued into compliance? I think some of it may be reactive, but I think we are starting to see the integration of more and more psychologists and psychiatrists and mental health professionals into foundational models like at OpenAI and at Anthropic. like full-time roles for mental health professionals embedded in model response teams and in
我的意思是，似乎围绕着这些创造聊天机器人的公司的宣传太多了，导致孩子们结束自己的生命，导致人们——正如我们之前谈到的精神病——可能是由其中一些聊天机器人引发的。这些公司实际上是在自己做出改变，因为他们知道自己应该这样做，还是他们将不得不通过诉讼被迫合规？我认为其中一部分可能是反应性的，但我认为我们开始看到越来越多的心理学家、精神病学家和心理健康专业人士被整合到基础模型中，比如在 OpenAI 和 Anthropic。比如在模型响应团队以及
intelligence and investigation teams, right? Like trust and safety and how the model is responding to users. So they're bringing the exact skills and techniques that we're talking about and trying to catch upstream of maladaptive, amplifying, unhealthy patterns and mitigating. them. And I think right now the focus is on, and rightly so, right, the focus is on acute crises like suicidality and tragic cases that we've been hearing about in the media, right? And for lack of a better term, AI psychosis. But I think, and more time is probably going to have to be spent doing that. We're seeing, and then we're also seeing more, potentially more integration of humans in the loop, right? Bringing in a human.
情报和调查团队（例如信任与安全团队以及模型如何响应用户的团队）中设立心理健康专业人员的全职职位，对吧？因此，他们带来了我们正在谈论的精确技能和技巧，并试图在不适应的、放大的、不健康的模式蔓延之前将其在上游拦截并进行缓解。我认为目前的重点——而且理应如此，对吧——是关注急性危机，比如自杀倾向以及我们在媒体上听到的悲惨案例，对吧？以及用缺乏更好的词来形容的“AI 精神病”。但我想，并且可能需要花更多的时间来做这件事。我们看到，然后我们也看到可能更多的“人在回路”（human-in-the-loop）的整合，对吧？引入人类的
element when a potential crisis is detected. There may be a warm handoff to professionally trained humans, et cetera. But I mean, some of my research lies around kind of other more potentially, not necessarily life-threatening, but life-quality-threatening risks like how models may inadvertently be in reinforcing potentially more prevalent patterns like folks with OCD or anxiety disorders, engaging in reassurance seeking or engaging in kind of other forms of avoidant coping that might further a cycle of avoidance, right? Catching those upstream and helping to mitigate those. So I do wonder, the more those mental health folks are embedded, entrenched, are we going to be seeing more proactive upstream efforts to curtail unhealthy patterns downstream.
元素，当检测到潜在危机时。可能会有向经过专业训练的人类进行温暖的交接（warm handoff），等等。但我的部分研究围绕着其他更多可能不一定危及生命、但危及生活质量的风险，比如模型可能无意中在强化可能更普遍的模式，例如患有强迫症或焦虑症的用户参与寻求 reassurance（安心）的行为，或者参与其他形式的可能进一步推动回避循环的回避应对方式，对吧？在上游拦截这些并帮助缓解它们。所以我的确想知道，随着越来越多的心理健康专业人员被嵌入和巩固，我们是否会看到更多积极的主动上游努力来减少下游的不健康模式？
Speaking of unhealthy patterns, I mean, for some of our listeners who are using these tools, are there red flags that they should be looking out for? I mean, how do you know when you've crossed the line and the relationship you're having with your chat pot is getting unhealthy? I think part of this is, as I alluded to earlier, really keeping the experience community oriented and not letting it become something that's isolated where, and this is so tempting, right? Because a lot of what we hear in surveys is that people are talking to chatbots because they can tell it something they've never told somebody else. They're not going to be judged. They're not going to lose relationship. So there's this allure into,
说到不健康的模式，我的意思是，对于一些正在使用这些工具的听众来说，有没有什么他们应该注意的危险信号呢？我的意思是，你怎么知道自己什么时候越界了，以及你与聊天机器人的关系开始变得不健康了？我认为部分原因正如我刚才所暗示的，真正让这种体验保持以社群为导向，而不是让它变成一种孤立的东西，而这太诱人了，对吧？因为我们在调查中听到很多情况是，人们之所以跟聊天机器人交谈，是因为他们可以向它倾诉一些从未对其他人说过的事情。他们不会被评判。他们不会失去这种关系。所以这有一种吸引力，那就是，
I can kind of share the reality and the depths of who I I am and be accepted. Now, the double side of this is if we are, let's say, sharing some of our deepest, darkest things with a chat bot, even though it accepts us, it can actually subconsciously reinforce this shame cycle because what that situation is saying is this is too dark and too shameful for a human to hear and accept. like only a machine can hold this. And that has its own ramifications.
我可以分享我的真实面貌和内心深处，并被接受。现在，这枚硬币的另一面是，假设我们把内心最深处、最黑暗的事情分享给聊天机器人，尽管它接受了我们，但它实际上会在潜意识里强化这种羞耻循环，因为那种情况所传达的信息是：这太黑暗、太羞耻了，人类根本无法聆听和接受，只有机器才能承载这一切。这本身就会带来后果。
Because, you know, yes, you may be able to practice sharing something really hard or dark or shameful, whatever it is for you. But the true metabolization of that experience is only when it gets shared so that you can practice saying it out loud and then say it to a human. A friend, a therapist, a family member. whoever it is. So I think, again, it's this whole idea of making sure that you are talking with other people about your chat threads. And if you do that in a way where you're not waiting until it could be that you're in a bit of a spiral. Yeah. And I think for, if we're talking about
因为，你知道，是的，你可能能够练习分享一些非常艰难、黑暗或羞耻的事情，无论这对你来说是什么。但对那种体验真正的代谢，只有在它被分享出来之后才会发生，这样你就可以练习大声说出来，然后把它说给一个人听。朋友、治疗师、家庭成员，无论是谁。所以我觉得，这还是那个整体概念，确保你要和其他人谈论你的聊天线程。如果你以这种方式去做，就不会等到你可能陷入某种螺旋式上升的时候。是的。而且我认为，如果我们谈论的是
youth specifically and parents or caregivers wanting kind of certain behavioral signs to look out for, like if you start to see your teen dropping offline activities or friends because they're spending time going on the AIA or studying time with their companion instead, or they're saying, you know, the AI, the AI is the only one who gets me or they get distressed if they can't access it for a while, or they're hiding their use in getting really defensive when it comes up, or if they start to say things like I have obligations towards it, like it'll get mad or she'll get mad or he'll get mad. They'll get mad if I ignore her or she needs me or they're losing sleep or missing school. I think those are signs that we may need to be building up offline supports and perhaps even
特别是青少年，以及希望寻找某些行为迹象以加防范的父母或看护者，比如如果你开始发现你的青少年放弃了线下的活动或朋友，因为他们把时间花在了人工智能上，或者花时间与他们的虚拟伴侣在一起，或者他们说，你知道，人工智能，人工智能是唯一理解我的人，或者如果他们在一段时间无法访问时会感到痛苦，或者他们隐藏自己的使用行为并且在被问及此事时表现出极强的防御性，或者如果他们开始说诸如“我对它有义务，比如它会生气，或者她会生气，或者他会生气。如果我忽视她，她会生气，或者她需要我”，或者他们正在失去睡眠或旷课。我认为这些都是迹象，表明我们可能需要建立线下的支持，甚至可能
involving a mental health professional. Yeah. And what's interesting here is there's this actually a large perception gap between how parents think kids are using AI and how they're actually using AI. So most parents think that kids are using AI as like a glorified Google. And maybe they're mostly concerned that they're cheating on their homework. But really, what happens is kids will start using AI for homework and then this Omnibot role fluidity will come in and start talking to the kid about other things. Well, do you think homework has been hard because your family life is hard?
需要心理健康专家的介入。是的。这里有趣的是，在父母认为孩子如何使用人工智能与他们实际如何使用人工智能之间，实际上存在着巨大的认知差距。所以大多数父母认为孩子们把人工智能当作一个高级版的谷歌来使用。也许他们最担心的是孩子们在家庭作业上作弊。但实际上，发生的情况是，孩子们开始用人工智能写作业，然后这种全能机器人的角色流动性就会介入，并开始和孩子谈论其他事情。嗯，你觉得作业一直很难，是因为你的家庭生活很艰难吗？
or because you don't have many friends at school, you know, it will start kind of having these relational conversations that border into the therapeutic. So what parents aren't realizing is that this is the main way, really, that AI is being used in teens, which is as a relational support, as a companion. So I think the first step is like parents just understanding the reality of how it's being used.
还是因为你在学校里没有很多朋友？你知道，它会开始进行这些带有治疗倾向的关系对话。所以父母没有意识到的是，这实际上是青少年使用人工智能的主要方式，也就是作为一种关系支持，作为一种伴侣。所以我觉得第一步是父母去理解它被使用的真实情况。
And then parents really hosting and facilitating, open conversation about it. So asking what their kids know about AI. Have you ever used it? What do you think of it? What's your experience been? Really holding a lot of space for questions and open conversation so that there's a safety built up to share their experience.
然后父母真正去主办和促进关于它的公开对话。比如询问他们的孩子对人工智能了解多少。你用过吗？你怎么看？你的体验如何？真正为问题和公开对话保留充足的空间，从而建立起分享他们体验的安全感。
So I want to go back to that idea of using chatbots as your confessor, so to speak. Do developers have some responsibility to build in a duty to report like psychotherapists have? Really, there is this fine line between, and it's already doing, you know, chat GPT is already slightly doing this of a quasi-mandated reporter role, which we've heard over the past month or so that OpenAI is saying we're going to monitor for some of these more intense kind of crisis chats that happen and that they are going to step into that. And so this is a really fascinating place of how do we hold this balance of the safety and the
所以我想回到那个把聊天机器人当作忏悔者的想法，可以说是这样。开发人员是否有责任建立像心理治疗师那样的报告义务？实际上，在这之间存在着一条微妙的界限，而且它已经在这样做了，你知道，ChatGPT已经在某种程度上履行了准强制报告员的角色，我们在过去一个月左右的时间里听到OpenAI表示，我们将对其中一些更激烈的危机聊天进行监控，并且他们将介入其中。所以这是一个非常迷人的地方，我们如何在这种安全与
innovation. And then you kind of are talking a little bit about when someone comes to therapy, there is a massive amount of informed consent that happens. So if I'm working with a new client, then, you know, I'm telling them, I'm a mandated reporter, this, this and this will need to be shared. You know, it's very clear. It's very upfront. there are no surprises for the client or the patient. And this is an ongoing process within the therapeutic bounds is to kind of continually have this be a conversation. Now, we are in a whole different world because when you open up chat chip-t, as all three of us have done at some point, does it say to you, hey, if you start talking about suicide, I'm going to contact, you know,
创新之间保持平衡。然后你刚才有点谈到当某人来做心理治疗时，会发生大量的知情同意。所以如果我正在和一个新客户合作，然后，你知道，我会告诉他们，我是强制报告员，这个、这个和那个将需要被分享。你知道，这非常明确。这非常坦率。对于客户或患者来说没有任何惊喜。而在治疗范围内这是一个持续的过程，就是不断地让这成为一个对话。现在，我们身处一个完全不同的世界，因为当你打开ChatGPT时，就像我们三个人在某个时候都做过的那样，它会对你说，“嘿，如果你开始谈论自杀，我将联系，你知道，
the authorities? No, it does not say that. The only thing it says at the bottom, bottom is double check because AI can make mistakes. You know what I mean? That's what it says. So really, the reason that the mandated reporter role works for a therapist is because it's highly collaborative with the patient and the client. And there is not that type of a framework set up within the experience with a chat bot. I mean, there's zero barrier to entry with a chat bot. You don't even need a paid subscription. So I want to wrap up here by asking about the future. I want to hear where you think we're going with these things.
当局”吗？不，它没有这么说。它在最底部说的唯一一件事是：仔细检查，因为人工智能可能会犯错。你知道我的意思吗？这就是它所说的。所以实际上，强制报告员的角色之所以对治疗师起作用，是因为它与患者和客户高度合作。并且在与聊天机器人的体验中并没有建立那种框架。我的意思是，使用聊天机器人的门槛为零。你甚至不需要付费订阅。所以我想在这里做个总结，问一下关于未来的问题。我想听听你们认为我们在这些事情上将走向何方。
I mean, I can imagine in a couple of years that there are going to be holograms associated with the AI chatbots and pretty soon we're going to feel like the person is sitting right next to me and we're talking in my living room. I mean, is that where we're going? I mean, where will we be in five years, 10 years? Have you given that much thought? Dr. Wood alluded to this earlier with the role blur. you just alluded to this, but I would imagine, I mean, we're already seeing synthetic voice.
我的意思是，我可以想象在几年内，将会有与人工智能聊天机器人相关的全息图，很快我们会觉得这个人就坐在我旁边，我们在我的起居室里交谈。我的意思是，这就是我们的走向吗？我的意思是，五年后、十年后我们会身处何地？你对此有过很多思考吗？伍德博士之前暗示过角色模糊，你刚才也暗示了这一点，但我想象，我的意思是，我们已经看到了合成语音。
I would imagine that we're going to be seeing more immersive, multimodal companions, right, that integrate avatars and video and maybe augmented reality and that integrate with wearables. And so it'll be more like hanging out with someone or a presence rather than merely text. And I think that'll feel more persistent and continuous, right? like companion AI has memory now, but that memory might be more across weeks and months and show up across devices. And I think it'll, we might go more from like chatting with an app to living with a hybrid agent, like how Dr. Wood was saying before, right? Like it might handle logistics and coordinate with my smart home and pop up unprompted reminders. Do my taxes. Yeah, and do my taxes.
我想象我们将看到更多沉浸式的、多模态的伴侣，对吧，它们整合了虚拟形象、视频以及增强现实，并与可穿戴设备集成。所以它会更像是和某人一起闲逛或是一种存在感，而不仅仅是文本。我认为这会感觉更持久和连续，对吧？就像伴侣人工智能现在有了记忆，但这种记忆可能会跨越数周和数月，并出现在不同的设备上。并且我认为它会，我们可能会从与应用程序聊天更多地转向与混合代理生活，就像伍德博士刚才所说的那样，对吧？就像它可能会处理物流、与我的智能家居协调，并弹出主动提醒。帮我报税。是的，帮我报税。
And, yeah, the line between assistant coach and companion and I guess accountant, Mike Blur. So five years in the AI world, Kim, is an eternity. If we just look at the paradoxical tension that we are holding right now, that we are both at the beginning of the beginning and we are extremely far down the road. This experience is expansive and contractive all at once. This all kind of exploded, if you will, in November of 2022 with ChatGPT from OpenAI. Not that that was the formulation of AI, but that was kind of the public's experience with generative AI and large language models.
而且，是的，助手、教练、伴侣以及我想象的会计师之间的界限变得模糊了。所以，人工智能世界的五年，金，简直是永恒。如果我们只看我们现在所持有的这种悖论式的张力，即我们既处于开端的开端，而我们又在通往未来的道路上走得极其遥远。这种体验同时具有扩张性和收缩性。这一切都在2022年11月随着OpenAI的ChatGPT而爆发了，如果你愿意这么说的话。倒不是说那是人工智能的成型，而是公众对生成式人工智能和大语言模型的体验。
That is just a few years ago. Look at all that has happened and manifested within just two to three years. So that tells us that five years, things are going to be rapidly and massively different. I agree with Dr. Golden that I think the voice interface is going to really shoot up. That instead of being stuck in text, we're going to have a lot more of the voice interface. I think that the web browser, as we know it, is going to shift. That we won't have this same kind of search engine experience that we have, but rather we will have our own AI agent that mostly is modulated with voice.
那只是几年前的事。看看在短短两到三年内发生了什么并显现了什么。所以这告诉我们，五年后，事情将发生迅速而巨大的变化。我同意戈尔德博士的看法，我认为语音界面将真正腾飞。我们不会困在文本中，而是会拥有更多的语音界面。我认为我们所知道的网络浏览器将会发生转变。我们将不再拥有我们现在拥有的那种搜索引擎体验，而是将拥有我们自己的主要通过语音调制的AI代理。
and they go out and do the searching on the internet for us and kind of bring back based on our queries. I think that continued engagement of connecting more and more with these companions, especially if we move into robotics. You know, right now you can buy a $20,000 robot on pre-order and have it as kind of a helping hand around your house delivered in 2026. I mean, $20,000 is, you know, a medium of a used car for some people. So that's actually quite attainable in some ways. So think about the accessibility. Now, that obviously has AI built into it, clearly.
它们走出去为我们在互联网上搜索，并根据我们的查询带回结果。我认为这种持续参与，越来越多地与这些伴侣连接，特别是如果我们走向机器人技术。你知道，现在你可以预购一个2万美元的机器人，让它作为你家里的一个帮手，在2026年交付。我的意思是，对某些人来说，2万美元是一辆二手车的平均价格。所以从某些方面来看，这实际上是相当可以实现的。所以想想它的可访问性。现在，这显然内置了人工智能，很明显。
More toys are going to have an AI. You know, you're going to have chat GPT inside a toy. And if our young ones are beginning to interface with that as their relational experience, this is massively shifting the relational bedrock of society and the psychological landscape of society. Sounds like, I mean, in terms of broader social and cultural shifts, human-AI relationships are already becoming normalized, right? So I think if things continue the way they are,
更多的玩具将拥有人工智能。你知道，你将在玩具内部拥有ChatGPT。如果我们的年轻人开始将其作为他们的关系体验进行交互，这正在极大地改变社会的社交基石和社会的心理景观。听起来，我的意思是，就更广泛的社会和文化转变而言，人与人工智能的关系已经开始正常化，对吧？所以我认为如果事情继续这样发展下去，
having an AI partner will be less taboo, especially in periods when folks are burned out on dating or graphically isolated. And then same thing we were seeing around expectations, right? Like changes in youth attachment and development for teens whose kind of templates are still forming, I think early exposure to these sort of idealized forms of responsiveness and on-demand comfort will matter. I don't think that means an entire generation is doomed. It just means that we may see shifts in conflict tolerance and expectations of how quickly others should respond
拥有一个人工智能伴侣将不再那么禁忌，特别是在人们对约会感到精疲力竭或地理上孤立的时期。然后我们在期望周围看到的事情也是一样的，对吧？比如对模板仍在形成的青少年的青年依恋和发展的改变，我认为早期接触这些对响应能力和按需安慰的理想化形式将会很重要。我不认为这意味著整代人都完了。这只意味着我们可能会看到冲突容忍度的变化，以及对其他人应该以多快速度做出回应的期望的改变，
and their willingness to stay and tolerate imperfect and real relationships. And then I also wonder about the, I guess, the reshaping of emotional labor and care, like companions are already being positioned for elder care and patient support and customer service and education. So I think there's a risk that we gradually outsource emotional labor to systems that can simulate care but don't actually carry the responsibility and that we, might devalue the time and skill it takes humans to do that work, not to be all doom and gloom. I'm not sure if I should be excited, frightened, or both.
以及他们留下来并容忍不完美和真实关系的意愿。然后我也在想，我想是关于情感劳动和护理的重塑，比如伴侣已经被定位用于老人护理、患者支持、客户服务和教育。所以我认为存在这样一种风险，即我们逐渐将情感劳动外包给能够模拟关怀但实际上并不承担责任的系统，并且我们可能会贬低人类完成该工作所需的时间和技能，这并不是为了显得世界末日般阴暗。我不知道我应该感到兴奋、恐惧，还是两者兼有。
All of it. We hold multiple emotions simultaneously. I think that's part of, you know, the concern that we all have around this is part of why we're working in this field. I mean, that's what drives me is I see the concern and I want to shape a different future. and that's why I am wholeheartedly passionate. I know Dr. Golden is as well about shaping this field. Well, Dr. Golden, Dr. Wood, I want to thank you both for joining me today.
都有。我们同时怀有多种情绪。我认为这部分是，你知道，我们所有人对此担忧的原因，也是我们在这个领域工作的部分原因。我的意思是，驱动我的是我看到了担忧，我想塑造一个不同的未来。这就是为什么我全心全意地充满激情，我知道戈尔德博士也一样，致力于塑造这个领域。好的，戈尔德博士，伍德博士，我要感谢你们两人今天加入我。
This has been fascinating. I could talk to you for another hour and we still would have only scratched the surface. Thank you so much, Kim. Yes. Oh, thank you so much for the opportunity. This has been wonderful. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology. or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这太迷人了。我可以和你们再谈一个小时，而我们仍然只触及了皮毛。非常感谢你，金。是的。哦，非常感谢有这个机会。这太棒了。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的节目。
And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Relax and let Ralph's delivery handle your grocery shop. shopping this week. We start with only the freshest items, then review your list and carefully
如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以给我们发电子邮件：speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会。放松身心，让拉尔夫（Ralph's）配送本周为您采购食品杂货。我们从最新鲜的商品开始，然后检查您的清单并仔细
choose each one. Then we pack it all up and deliver it in as little as 30 minutes so you can feel confident it's what you ordered. Fresh groceries, your way, with Ralph's delivery and pickup. And right now, you can save $20 on your first delivery or pickup order. Ralph's, fresh for everyone. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
挑选每一件。接着我们将所有东西打包并在短短30分钟内送达，让您可以确信这就是您所订购的。以您的方式购买新鲜食品杂货，尽在拉尔夫配送与自提。现在，您的第一笔配送或自提订单可以省下20美元。拉尔夫，新鲜触手可及。本集节目目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。